previously on TV since we brought home
Indian food I see in your lot and I
think that you're really pretty and
would you want to go out with me the
show winners realized the real star of
the show during the first season was
obviously monkey so they decided to
stuff the rest of the series with more
chickens ducks roosters and smelly cats
than you can shake a ball er net oh you
are really not a morning person and how
would Monica not know this in the four
plus years they live together Monica has
never experienced Rachel in the morning
why isn't everyone even anyone other
than Rachel and Monica trying to figure
out what that insane noises you telling
me that dude in the apartment below them
that's so goddamn sensitive to noise
wouldn't be up here raising hell hang on
Ross brought a hat to this credit shoot
a hat when was I had ever featured in
this intro in any season nobody else has
a hat
what are you doing shopping thanks to
somebody's dumbass rooster Rachel might
want to explain this a little better as
far as Ross and Phoebe know it was
Chandler's cockadoodledoo that will
corrupt you really should get rid of
those animals they shouldn't be living
in an apartment nor could they really
considering the noise that they're
making would have certainly had someone
alerting the super by now thanks
strangely enough think thick was what my
college girlfriend said when I asked her
what she wanted for Christmas you can
only eat tic tacs in even numbers yeah
what's that about well it could be a
mild form of obsessive-compulsive
disorder but more likely it's something
a writer thought up and decided might be
funny but it was but the audience
laughed anyhow because sit down
you're good these are not did Ross just
put back a cookie he took a bite out of
in the box seriously if anyone tells you
Ross is their favorite friend change
your number move immediately and don't
leave a forwarding address
also Ross doesn't like cookies he
doesn't like cookies if we don't find
out soon that Ross is an actual serial
killer I'm calling for an indigent how
many items left in that bag five okay
ten bucks says the we can name every
item in that bag that would be
impressive what would be more impressive
is knowing how the chairman was able to
follow what Joey wanted to do without
any kind of conversing beforehand stop
that now in this heated game of what's
in the bag not only is Chandler now
close enough to see inside the bag he
even stole a glance that way I'm just
saying if these friends are as
competitive as we're being led to
believe Monica would have tackled in the
second he took a step toward her sack
we'll start with apples yes
director said let's not only have you
annoyingly effect a game show host voice
but also let you hold a bag of apples
it'll make it look like some super duper
[ __ ] no no not for like another two
weeks yes because if there's one thing I
know about women it's that they wait to
shop for their monthly supplies on
chicken day at the Red Roof Inn
sure Ross will do it sound like he has a
job or a child or a life of his own well
to be fair buddy I'm not sure this show
is very aware of those things either do
five because that gives you a 25% chance
that at least one will attach wholly
they're just now learning this she's
like
ready to put those up in there kind of
doctor's office waits until the last
minute to give the most important
information about the procedure okay
that's a lot of pressure on me and my
uterus it's like this episode is daring
me to break the college girlfriend joke
record the first team to answer the most
questions wins first or the most how do
you become the first team to answer the
most questions doesn't that mean the
first team to answer a single question
wins damn it Ross we trusted you also
you didn't even say correctly answer so
now I'm not even sure if anyone has to
get anything right at all just blurt out
anything and it counts you thought we
were tough on poker the categories are
fears and pet peeves those are two
distinct categories Ross you really are
the worst at this the I was jig guy it's
legs flail about as if independent from
his body
that's gigas every week the TV Guide
comes to Chandler and Joey's apartment
Ross includes a TV Guide address label
question in the literature category
filing the TV Guide under literature's
like filing cinema send under movie
reviews could you imagine hi Jesus
Christ they just left those embryos out
on a platter and left the room and we
sure this doctor's office isn't just the
corner of a warehouse deep in Hell's
Kitchen
also it's hilarious that they titled the
episode specifically after Phoebe's
embryo B's story when the only thing
anyone remembers about this shows the
contest at Monica's apartment
you don't have to shout everything what
is up with the writers giving obvious
character lines to other characters
this is totally a Monica reaction to
this game as the resident hyper
competitive neurotic I'm not even
playing for the apartment yet all right
bye luckily do you mean it was written
that way if you're gonna go through all
the work of preparing an entire
lightning round
drawing a lightning bolt on the
questions and sealing them in an
envelope why leave the chance that gets
wasted just make it part of the actual
contest awesome you could just ask the
12 remaining questions on the board
behind you but like a cool lightning
bolt drawings if you win give up the
bird but if we win we get your apartment
do you mean you trade apartments or are
you saying you'll have residency of both
apartments terms of this better so
poorly defined I don't even know where
the sin is oh there it is
also a rent controlled two-bedroom
apartment in 90s New York versus a
couple of fowls is a totally fair bet
sitcoms and their contents it coming you
have 30 seconds the guys timer will last
43 seconds and what part of her body did
Monica get a pencil stuck at age 14 oh
no everything is wrong about the
practicalities of this part of the scene
but the thing that sticks most in my
craw is Chandler's blatant disregard for
the ticking clock the gals time will
last 45 seconds the lightning round
begins obvious horrible dubbing is
horribly obvious what is Chandler Bing's
job
why isn't skip an option here could have
saved an entire unnecessary storyline
actually it takes about 16 also even if
they get this they would still lose the
game right they need five to win and
they've only answer three and Ty's go to
the penis they all know that we also
also if we zoom in enhance cliche the
timer at the end it is clearly stopped
on 5 minutes and 23 seconds look all I'm
saying is that there hasn't been a quiz
competition and this controversial since
stemple and Van Doren got all the
answers from Moe Szyslak and the bus
driver from heart and souls and that
ladies and gentlemen is how Jason
Statham movie titles are made oh my god
don't mention the nipples don't mention
the nipples don't mention the nipples
wait I say that alone nope actually not
for another nine years
Seth Rogen is only 16 at this point and
Paul Rudd is still ageless this is what
I told my penis at 9:15 every evening
Joey took the time to not only box but
label his stuff
they are literally moving across the
hall it would take more time to box all
this up and label it then it wouldn't
just carry stuff over by hand
you guys you're gonna have a baby
they're gonna have a baby baby ex
machina I award you no points and may
God have mercy on your soul okay a
simple wrong would have done just fine
but oh you are really not a morning
person you go to hell you dad
[Music]
what are the odds like if if like you
stuff like 200 of them in their rear
head you are giving him the wrong idea
about sex you need to call it I can't
call it for you you wouldn't be fair
gentlemen pick your category I'll take
anal bum cub up for something I can't
believe you guys actually think you're
moving in here
what no it was a stupid bet we were just
playing a game you pay me